with me now Philip Ingram former British
Army intelligence and security officer
um so Philip let's start by talking
about these attacks in the early hours
of the morning for ukrainians
um can we presume that this was a direct
response to zelenski's movements over
the weekend and the deals agreed with
Western allies yes almost certainly you
know day 447 of Vladimir Putin's 10-day
special military operations and here we
have pictures allegedly of the Pietro
batteries in Kiev shooting down the
Russian Hypersonic missiles the kh-47m2
of which six of the missiles that came
in were of that Hypersonic variety
um and it's the only response really the
Russians have got whenever zielinski is
out interacting with the International
Community the International Community
are giving them anything
um and they even got upset at Eurovision
you're at the weekend they attacked
Turner pole which is the hometown of the
Ukrainian Eurovision Song Contest entry
group that was there so he's got nothing
nothing else really apart from this
um as the Ukrainian counter-offensive
started because obviously the fighting
continues but in terms of reacting to
what he felt last night what's happening
well that's the six million dollar
question
um and it depends on how you define how
it started the major ground defensive to
take large areas of territory back off
the Russians no but there are a number
of small offenses that have got going on
around the place to continue to prepare
the battle space and to fix the Russians
and place bakmud we've been talking
about it for months and months and
months the Wagner
private military company are still
attacking into the center of bakmutton
pushing in through there I'm gaining
tens of meters but the ukrainians are
actually coming in and have been
counter-attacking to the north of bakmut
and to the south of bakmut and Reporting
from the Ukrainian Ministry of defense
today says they've got about 20 square
kilometers of territory back again this
is a fixing operation it's fixing the
Russians attention
um both from a military perspective and
a psychological perspective in this area
as the ukrainians prepare for potential
counter-offensives either here if they
can get through or elsewhere so zelenski
continuing to recruit military aid
Russia attacking the capital with
missiles what about the diplomacy and
trying to find an end to this war where
are we on that well war is diplomacy by
other means
um there will be calls for negotiations
going on at the moment
um Cyril ramaphosa from the um uh from
South Africa has got South African
delegation of leaders that are going to
go to cave and to Moscow to try and put
in a peace initiative however for peace
initiative to work the conditions in the
ground have to be right and those
conditions in the ground aren't right we
have to see a Ukrainian ground
counter-offensive to push the Russians
out because Vladimir Putin does want to
give up what he's got and that
counteroffensive will either come in
through heart cave in the north to take
a big chunk of territory back again to
start with bakmut as we've been talking
about or done in this done in the South
um uh potentially from zaparisia down to
Mario Paul or milio pool I'm trying to
split that land bridge from Crimea up
into the donbass region this has to
happen I think before the ukrainians
will even think that they're in a
position to carry out any negotiations